TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The room and lifecycle
Architecture Components
libraries have
reached 1.0 stable,
which means they are ready for
production apps and libraries.
These foundational
components make
it possible to write modular
apps with less boilerplate code
so you can focus on
innovating instead
of reinventing the wheel.
You can get started with the
post linked in the description
below.
In 11.6.0 of the Google
Play Services SDK,
we're introducing a major
change in the APIs meant
to make them easier
to use, thread safe,
and more memory efficient.
We've deprecated the
Google API client class
and introduced a
de-coupled collection
of feature-specific API clients.
All the details and sample
code are on the post.
TensorFlow 1.4 is now available.
Included in the changes,
both Keras and datasets
have graduated to core packages.
For more details on
these and other updates,
check out the post.
Tangent is a new, free, and
open source Python library
for automatic
differentiation, and
its source-to-source system,
consuming a Python function F
and emitting a new
Python function that
computes the gradient of F.
This allows much better user
visibility into
gradient computations,
as well as easy
user-level editing
and debugging of gradients.
We're excited to
announce that we're
adding Domain Name System
Security Extension support
to our fully-managed
Google Cloud DNS service.
Now you and your users
can take advantage
of the protection
provided by DNSSEC
without having to maintain
it once it's set up.
Screenshots are on the post.
Google Cloud Dataprep,
which has been
available to the public in a
beta release for just a month,
had its first public
update on Thursday.
Included is a fresh UI, job
scheduling, and richer sampling
options.
Details for each are on the
post linked in the description
below.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for watching yet another
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you missed some of
our previous episodes,
maybe click on them
right over here.